behavior no matter what piece of
legislation is passed
respectfully sometimes lawmakers have no
idea what it means to be a responsible
veteran and to continue to pass laws
that you were
in freedom rights and make the
followings we are allowed to operate
when unsafe
for example in the same category we have
a handgun roster in our current ar-15
walls
currently ar-15 laws and the
modifications that are required
actually make these style of rifles that
we are literally able to
possess no prone to firing accidents
additionally with the california
approved handgun roster you can only
purchase older
outdated firearms with older and
outdated safety features
what sense does that make when firearm
safety enhancements are made and
improved by gun manufacturers often
yet californians are only prohibited
from purchasing the notice and safest
firearms
the finance industry has unfairly been
under assault
as a result my husband and i have
dedicated our lives to ensuring our
communities have
the resources and knowledge they need to
be successful in the firearm space
part of being a responsible benefit is
ensuring that there are resources
available for them to be consulted
educated and trained in a welcoming
environment
being a leader of the national african
american gun association has allowed me
the ability to extend
my educational reach from my firearms
store to the 40 000 members that are
part of that organization
the second of the amendment is
and controversial moments of our
constitution but many would like to see
laws created
that would fail to impede our right to
their arms i look forward to using my
time today
and beyond to continue to educate on
what it means to be a responsible
firearm owner how many of us
successfully view their responsibilities
on a daily basis and how common sense
gun knowledge can aid in the retainment
of our rights
thank you thank you very much ms solomon
i apologize to the committee members and
others that the
audio quality is so poor uh we're going
to look into this
somebody's being paid to communicate
with us and it's not working very well
and we owe the respect to the witnesses
who made a sacrifice to testify
for the committee to provide them with a
means of communication we can all hear
our next witness is chris chang mr chang
chairman durbin ranking member grassley
and distinguished members of the
committee
my name is chris chang and i'm honored
to join you today representing myself
and only myself as a gay asian american
sport professional sports shooter
this hearing is very timely and
essential to our national conversation
on civil rights and our future as a
peaceful nation
i'm here today to share my
quintessential american story
in 2012 i earned the title of history
channel's top shot season 4 champion
now only in america could a self-taught
amateur shooter
train and win a hundred thousand dollars
in a professional shooting contract
after this i quit my job at google and
switched careers and focused on firearms
culture and their role in american
history
i earned a master's degree in policy
studies from middlebury college in 2006.
following my top shot win i naturally
wanted to research gun policy in history
but i was appalled to discover how gun
control can be used as a tool of
discrimination
while our black brothers and sisters
have arguably experienced the most
negative impacts of gun control through
structural racism at the hands of the
government
asian americans have also been
negatively impacted
i will share two examples first
the chinese exclusion act of 1882 was
the first
federal law to explicitly prohibit the
immigration of people
of a particular nationality and set an
extremely
dangerous precedent for a future for
future xenophobic mandates
second in response to mounting pressures
during world war ii
executive order 9066 mandated that more
than 110
000 innocent japanese americans were to
be forcibly relocated to internment
camps
this order stripped my japanese
ancestors of their rights and their
civil liberties
the goal was to keep us unarmed
invisible
and silent neither the chinese exclusion
act nor the executive order
was genuinely successful in increasing
domestic safety
neither will the gun control legislation
under consideration
why are these historic moments important
for our conversation today
i'll explain with the 149 percent
increase in anti-asian american violence
over the past
year asian americans are flocking in
droves to buy guns
many seeking to purchase their first
firearm
there is a real need and imminent threat
we need to defend ourselves not three
days or 20 days from now
but right now
i encourage people to be their own first
responder because there is no guarantee
that help will arrive in time
universal background checks will not
help i live in san francisco
and if i want to give or sell a personal
firearm to a friend or family member
they must wait 10 days there should not
be a timer
delaying when an american wants to
exercise their second amendment right
or any other individual right
every year millions of americans legally
purchase firearms
in comparison only a few thousand
criminals are mentally ill
individuals acquire guns and commit
homicide
will you let the criminal minority take
away the rights of the law-abiding
majority
rights which are supposed to be
guaranteed to us by our constitution
against hr8 and h.r 1446 because they
represent a threat
to the safety of asian americans and all
americans
who have an imminent need to defend
themselves
earlier i spoke about the racist roots
of gun control
but what's worse than systemic racist
gun control policies poorly thought out
gun control policies that will
negatively impact
americans of all walks of life all races
genders and sexual orientations in
america
i'll expand i'm miguel mayer i'm a gay
american
and have been happily married to my
husband of five and a half years
today we see a rise in attacks against
asian americans
but tomorrow i might be back here
talking about the persistent ongoing
violence against lgbtq americans
i've lived through how the phrase gay
virus
to describe aids stokes the same fears
and dehumanization elicited by the words
chinese virus
this derogatory language contributes to
a less safe
less empathetic society i'll continue
speaking out against hate and violence
in all forms
and i encourage all americans to
participate in what should be a
simple universal condemnation of hate
and violence we should not be afraid of
saying that we will not
tolerate it that it is unacceptable and
that it
must stop at the root of our country's
violence is not firearms
the root causes of human violence and
hate are many
low self-esteem lack of mental health
resources
community education job opportunities
and a lack of humanity
congress must focus on these actual
causes of violence that will make
america safer thank you for allowing me
to address this committee on the
importance of gun safety
and education and condemn the brutality
ravaging our communities today
thank you mr chang our next witness is
the waterbury connecticut chief of
police fernando spagnola
thank you mr chairman before i start my
testimony i would like to express my
deepest
sympathies to the families of all that
were lost in the boulder colorado
shooting yesterday
especially the family and co-workers of
fellow officer eric talley who
i bravely trying to protect his
community chief if you could uh
be a little closer perhaps to
so we could hear you a little better
thank you sir
chairman durbin ranking member grassley
and distinguished members of the
judicial committee
thank you for inviting me to testify
today my name is fernando spagnolo and i
am the chief of police
for the city of waterbury connecticut i
have dedicated most of my adult life to
public service
sworn to protect the people and uphold
the constitution i am honored to testify
before you today on common sense
solutions to prevent gun violence
when the national press talks about gun
violence in connecticut it usually
discusses the brutal and unspeakable
murders
at sandy hook high school in newtown
nearly 10 years ago
the events of that day and the loss of
those young children and their teachers
shook this nation to its very core as
chief administrator of one of the
largest police departments in the state
of connecticut
the gun violence that i am most familiar
with rarely makes national headlines
but it is just as consequential to the
people that it affects
the toll of daily gun violence
disproportionately affects black and
brown communities in cities like mine
across this country
is a serious problem and it requires
serious solutions
following sandy hook the people of
connecticut work together to improve the
state's existing laws and develop
comprehensive strategies to reduce gun
violence
including instituting universal
background checks a common-sense policy
supported by almost every american as
someone who is responsible for the
safety of men and women in uniform
ensuring that all individuals getting a
background check before the firearm can
be transferred
and ensuring enough time is provided for
that background check
is a top priority of mine we also
expanded the state's assault weapon ban
and outlawed sales of new high-capacity
ammunition magazines
likewise we've heightened protections
for victims of domestic violence in
connecticut after laurie jackson was
murdered by her estranged husband
with a gun he was able to purchase even
though he was under a temporary
protective order
a woman is shot and killed every 16
hours in america
by a current or former romantic party
and this is something that needs to be
addressed
most recently we passed ethan's law a
common sense measure that requires guns
to be safely stored if children might
have access to them
this is a law named in honor of ethan
song a 15 year old boy from guilford
connecticut
who died unintentionally when shot with
an unsecured gun
nationwide nearly 4.6 million children
live in homes with access to unsecured
and loaded guns
and eight children are unintentionally
shot with an unsecured firearm daily
these policies have been built off
connecticut's existing gun laws
including the nation's first extreme
risk law known in our state as a risk
warrant
this allows law enforcement officers to
petition a court to temporarily separate
an individual from firearms
if they pose a risk of imminent harm to
themselves or others
according to recent studies for every 10
to 20 risk warrants
that appeared in connecticut one suicide
is prevented
in addition to these common sense laws
in waterbury we have invested in
community solutions to prevent gun
violence
we partner with local leaders
institutions and non-profits to help
remove the root causes of violence in
our community
this includes youth violence prevention
programs one-on-one mentoring programs
for high-risk youth
and providing mental health and
substance abuse recovery services to
members of our community
it also includes an annual gum buyback
program which gets about 100 firearms
off the street each year
additionally to break the cycle of
violence and reduce recidivism
we have post incarceration violence
prevention programs that facilitate
services
such as housing health care harm
reduction
workforce training education and
faith-based outreach
this is especially important as the
majority of weapons offenses in
waterbury are being committed by
individuals with fire
weapons convictions as recently released
individuals are being reintegrated into
society
often with their support networks in
disarray we must find ways
to give them stake in their future and
their communities to reduce recidivism
and prevent further violence the efforts
to prevent gun violence in connecticut
have worked in 2019 waterbury
experienced some of its lowest levels of
gun violence in years
statewide since 2014 we have seen a 41
reduction in gun homicides and a 15
percent reduction in gun suicides
in the midst of kogan 19 in the huge
surge in gun purchases nationwide
incidents of gun violence have
skyrocketed in cities all over the
country
and waterbury is no exception to that
despite the recent setbacks connecticut
still has one of the lowest gun death
rates in the nation
but connecticut is not an island and
without federal action we remain at the
mercy of states with wheat gun laws
over two-thirds of the crime guns chased
by law enforcement in connecticut
come from other states and gun
traffickers will continue to exploit
weaknesses in the federal law
unless we can stop the unchecked flow of
guns into cities like mine
preventing cycles of violence will be
almost impossible
gun violence is not inevitable and for
the members of this body you are in a
position to enact sensible solutions
that are in line with the second
amendment
preventing gun violence requires a
comprehensive approach and a strong
investment in our communities
i'm grateful for this opportunity and i
look forward to your questions
thanks very much chief our next witness
is amy swearer
amy thank you for being with us please
proceed
chairman durbin ranking member grassley
and distinguished senators
my name is amy swearer and i'm a legal
fellow in the heritage foundation's ed
me center for legal and judicial studies
imagine with me for a moment a man who
walks into his primary care doctor
with a whole host of complex underlying
overlapping health issues
he suffers from a heart defect he's
overweight he's prone to migraines
he probably needs a hip replacement and
he also happens to have a very serious
high ankle sprain
now is that man's injured ankle a true
physical ailment that negatively impacts
his overall health
of course should the doctor treat it
absolutely
would any sane doctor look at that
patient and decide the most prudent
course of action
is emergency surgery to amputate his leg
absolutely not far too many of the gun
control bills pending before congress
are nothing more than the public policy
version of this scenario
in short they would cut off the
patient's leg to fix a comparatively
minor part of his overall health
problems
and then claim that this complete
overkill of a treatment
somehow left the patient better off in
the long run
we cannot do public policy this way
hr 8 on universal background checks is
just
one example of this but it is a profound
example hr8 identifies at its core
a legitimate concern publicly advertised
interstate gun sales
by private parties now we know
that these sales don't play a major role
in gun crime
most would-be criminals don't bother to
get their guns through any legitimate or
formal source
they primarily use black market gun
sales straw purchases
or informal transfers from friends or
family members who already know
that they are prohibited persons and
that the guns are likely to be used
to perpetrate crimes these are already
illegal gun transfers
now still it it might make sense to
address publicly advertised private
sales
but only with the understanding that
this is at best a low reward endeavor
and it should be obvious that the law
ought to similarly
avoid imposing heavy burdens on
law-abiding gun owners
making other common low risk gun
transfers
hr 8 almost goes out of its way to do
the opposite
as i explained in my written submission
there are a number
of irrational components to hr8
but without a doubt what is most
concerning is the way in which hra
places significant
mental emotional and practical barriers
between responsible gun owners
and low-risk informal gun transfers that
save countless lives every year
the bill limits temporary emergency
transfers to only when
they're necessary to prevent imminent
death or great bodily harm
and the transfers can last only as long
as immediately necessary
senators i have no doubt that the
language for this carve out is
well-intentioned
but it's so limited as to serve no real
purpose
nearly two-thirds of all gun deaths
every year are suicides 24
000 americans killed themselves with
firearms in 2019
there's every reason to believe that
number is higher for 2020.
mental health awareness and suicide
prevention are
vital but often difficult conversations
for gun owners
there's a very real and frankly a very
legitimate fear
that if we are open and honest about our
mental health difficulties
politicians and gun control activists
will use it to impose
crushing long-term consequences on our
second amendment rights
so one very common solution is to seek
informal help
and to leave firearms with trusted
friends or family members
the moment we realize that we're not
okay and for as long
as we realize we are not okay i can't
stress enough
how important this mechanism is for
suicide prevention
and how often it occurs precisely
because it is
informal many gun owners who might
otherwise agree to temporarily hand over
their
firearms will balk at that same
suggestion
if it means they have to publicly
traipse down to a gun store
wait around for a background check and
legally relinquish
title and ownership of their guns to
someone else
this is a deeply personal issue for me
like everyone else i've had ups and
downs in this life
and as a responsible gun owner i have
made
that very prudent decision to ask
friends to temporarily take my guns
when i've been down the last
thing the last thing i would have needed
was the government
getting in the way of me doing the right
thing
and i speak on behalf of countless other
gun owners who have made
this same responsible decision under
similar circumstances
but who would be terrified of admitting
that to anyone much less to the federal
government
now mrs brule testified about a very
real problem with existing law that to
her is not
small in scope because it shook the
foundations of her entire world
and there are certainly appropriate ways
of addressing and narrowly tailoring
legislation to address that problem
but this this is not it
hr8 as written will get gun owners
killed because it will discourage them
from taking
reasonable and common sense steps the
moment
they realize they may not in fact be
okay
there are many other similar problems
with with so many other gun control
bills and i
genuinely look forward to talking about
how to fix those problems and find
alternate solutions
but with respect to hr8 in particular
please
do not encourage gun owners to wait
until they're in imminent danger to take
life-saving actions
this is not a choice between thoughts
and prayers and doing something
regardless of how impractical that
something is and how poorly it works in
real world scenarios this is the world's
greatest deliberative body surely
we can do better than making criminals
of people who
do the right things thank you and i look
forward to answering your questions
thank you swear next witness is dr
susannah
hopp dr hub
there we go good morning my name is
susannah hupp
and this is my own testimony i'm
representing only myself this morning
and i need to apologize to some of you
in advance that have heard my testimony
before it really doesn't change
several years ago i was with my parents
at a local cafeteria
and somebody drove his truck through a
floor-to-ceiling window
knocked over a number of tables on his
way in
and we of course thought it was an
accident
my parents and i actually got up to try
to help the people that he had knocked
over
and then we heard gunshots and i will
tell you it took a good 45 seconds which
is an eternity
to realize that the guy was simply going
to walk around and shoot people
back then these mass shootings weren't
happening and it just wasn't something
that came to my mind immediately
when i did realize what was happening my
father and i both got down on the floor
we put the table up in front of us my
mother was down behind us
and i reached for my purse because i
used to carry a gun in my purse
and at that time in the state of texas
that was illegal
a few months prior to this event i had
begun to leave
my or i had begun to leave my gun out in
my car because i was concerned about
losing my license to practice
chiropractic
so i watched completely helplessly
as this man walked around the room
and shot people he executed people
like they were fish in a barrel when my
father
thought he had an opportunity
he rose up and he ran at the man
but the guy had complete control over
the situation and he just simply turned
and shot my father in the chest
when i saw what i thought was a chance i
was able to run out of back window
that somebody had broken out i thought
my mother followed me
but i later found out from the police
officers who by the way were one
building away
that she had crawled out into the open
where my dad lay
she cradled him until the gunman got
back around to her
he put a gun to her head they said she
looked up at him
put her head down and the man pulled the
trigger
that's how the cops knew who the gunman
was
my parents had just had their 47th
wedding anniversary mom wasn't going
anywhere without that
i was very angry and of course when i
talk about it even now i get very angry
believe it or not i'm not mad at the guy
that did it because in my opinion
that's somebody who is sick
the cops said all they had to do was
fire a shot into the ceiling and he
rabbited to a back bathroom alcove area
exchanged some gunfire with him and then
put a bullet in his own head
i was mad as hell at my legislators
because they had legislated me and
others in that restaurant
out of the right to be able to to defend
ourselves
i had a perfect place to pop my hand i
had a clear shot at the guy
but i was worried about losing my
license instead of worrying about my
life
since then of course we've changed those
laws in texas and all across the nation
now people can defend themselves in most
places
most of the mass shootings that have
occurred to this date
have been in places where people have
been told they can't carry a gun
that's what these guys want they want to
wrap up a high body bag count they don't
want
any place where somebody can fire back
at them
a gun isn't a guarantee of course it
changes
the odds that's all and i would say if
if
guns are the problem then why don't we
see these mass shootings at
the dreaded gun show or nra conventions
places where there are thousands of guns
in the hands of at least as many
law-abiding
citizens you talk about universal
background checks and i i am frankly
completely against them and here's why
eventually universal background checks
become a de facto registration
and even if no one on the dynast today
is interested in confiscating guns
it certainly makes it fertile ground for
some future despot
there are things that can be done
uh a number of them i put in my written
testimony and i won't
bore you with it now but they're there
there are things that can be done
let me just finish by saying
350 million
guns in america last year
didn't hurt anyone and i think that
is a staggering statistic
thank you thanks dr hub
our last witness is robin thomas miss
thomas
thank you chairman durbin members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
here today my name is robin thomas and
i'm the executive director of the
giffords law center to prevent gun
violence
giffords law center was formed more than
25 years ago
after a mass shooting at a san francisco
law firm and renamed for former
congresswoman gabby giffords after
joining forces
with the organization that she leads
i've been the executive director at the
law center since 2006.
this past week we saw a horrible string
of shootings
10 people including a law enforcement
officer in boulder colorado yesterday
last tuesday nine people were shot and
eight killed at three spas in the
atlanta area
a shocking example of the disturbing
increase in violence against the
asian-american community
over the last year communities have
suffered not only from covid19
but also from gun violence a public
health crisis that has surged in all of
its forms
suicides have increased dramatically in
communities from philadelphia to chicago
domestic violence has also intensified
with many localities reporting more
calls to hotlines and police
in response to incidents of abuse many
metropolitan areas have experienced
spikes in community violence with over a
dozen
cities reporting increases in homicides
of 50 percent or more
we cannot allow this evidence this
violence to continue for the next
generation proposed gun law reforms
many of which have been introduced in
this congress
and which enjoy widespread public
support would
make a difference these include policies
such as universal background checks
extreme risk protection laws and
prohibitions on firearm access to those
who commit domestic abuse
or hate crimes they also include
proposals to fund
to increase funding for critical
community violence intervention work
public health research and for law
enforcement
these proposals are a crucial part of an
appropriate public health approach
focused on prevention proportional to
the seriousness of this issue
and based on the data and research we
have for these solutions
despite what the gun lobby may argue
there is no constitutional impediment to
passing life-saving gun laws
courts across the country have ruled
repeatedly that the second amendment
does not stand in the way of passing
stronger gun laws
and the u.s supreme court itself made
clear that the rights secured by the
second amendment is not
unlimited and has never protected a
right to keep and carry
any weapon whatsoever in any manner
whatsoever
and for whatever purpose i know some are
eager to make the case that we are only
interested in taking away firearms from
law abiding americans
or making it difficult for law
enforcement to do their jobs
i want to be clear that we are not
advocating for either
but our existing gun laws are
irrationally limited
loophole ridden and inadequate and these
deficiencies hamper law enforcement's
ability to effectively prevent acts of
gun violence
in our american communities everyone
should be troubled by the levels of gun
violence that we experience
and it's impossible to ignore the
reality that when we have more
guns we have more gun violence
we can meaningfully address this by
updating our gun laws
to ensure both law-abiding americans
have a right to gun ownership
and we can prevent these horrific acts
of gun violence that are occurring on a
daily basis
since the founding of our country gun
rights have always coexisted with gun
regulations
and the need to propel to protect public
safety has
always gone hand in hand with americans
right to own guns
heller's explicit recognition that a
broad range of gun laws are
fully consistent with the second
amendment is in keeping with more than
200 years of
the united states reached their highest
level in almost 40 years with 40
000 americans dying from gun violence in
2019
unfortunately it's a problem unique to
our country
americans are 25 times more likely to be
killed by a gun than people in other
developed nations
but it's a problem that has solutions
while one single
law will never stop all gun violence we
know
that strong gun laws will save lives the
only thing standing in the way of laws
that prevent needless injuries and death
and enjoy the support of an overwhelming
majority of americans
is the absence of political will to act
so today i ask all members of this
committee and congress as a whole
to recommit themselves to making
progress and taking action
to reduce gun violence in this country
thank you again mr chairman and i look
forward to taking your questions
thank you very much for your testimony
let me start with dr rogers
we face two realities certainly from a
chicago perspective
that a lot of the gun violence has been
spawned by
young people gangs and
communities that are washing guns
you know what i'm speaking of south side
west side of chicago and many other
places
we also know that many of the shooters
have a history
at least a history of adverse childhood
experiences
could you explain to us that issue of
trauma
and the likelihood that it will lead to
shooters and victims
thank you dr durbin many people know
the phrase or heard the phrase hurt
people
hurt people and work from john rich and
john rich and ted kerbin in philadelphia
has shown repeatedly that people who
have been
experiencing trauma from adverse
childhood experiences of trauma be it
related to homelessness
food insecurity and other uh social
challenges are more likely to be at risk
of
experiencing trauma in all those forms
be it
um child abuse domestic violence or
other forms of trauma
unfortunately those who have been
victims of gun violence
we also know have a higher risk of being
having repeated episodes of gun violence
and in many ways
those are the highest risk individuals
and we need to find ways of addressing
that
those high-risk individuals in
economically
depressed communities that are the
highest risk for being
victims of violence but also
perpetrators of violence
doctor i hate to interrupt you but 18
months ago that would have been an
answer
that would have been really spot on
now i want you to add cobot 19 into the
equation
without a doubt the covert 19 pandemic
for a whole host of reasons related to
social isolation
higher rates of unemployment and other
challenges
of the covert 19 pandemic has put
incredible pressure on distressed
communities
higher rates of unemployment higher
rates of mental
on wellness if you will has perpetuated
more
gun violence we've seen in the city of
chicago and many cities across the
country
including la and philadelphia
50 increase the rate of gun violence
and we need more targeted interventions
to try to address this problem
problem unfortunately every day is not
going away we know that over 100 people
will die today
of gun related homicides and suicides so
let me ask you this question
a child who has gone through these
adverse childhood experiences in a
childhood that none of us wish on anyone
is that child a lost soul is there any
possible
redemption in terms of medical treatment
or mental
health treatment you know i think we
often you know every child is an
opportunity
and we need to invest in our children
because those children are the ones who
become adults and productive members of
our society
unfortunately oftentimes those
trauma is not recognized and the impact
of that trauma and intergenerational
trauma
such as poverty and racism is not
addressed
uh finding ways of actually providing
trauma-informed care
to individuals be it in schools and in
communities
we can have an impact and prevent
needless
intentional gun violence and other forms
of trauma thank you
chief spagnolum so far this year 16
chicago police officers have been either
shot
or shot at in the line of duty last week
alone three officers were shot and
injured
we know what happened last night in
boulder the policeman who responded
to the scene eric talley father of seven
lost his life can you talk about the
risk that law enforcement officers face
while america is seeing record numbers
of guns that are being
sold and also should a gun be sold to an
unknown person without that person
passing a criminal background check
mr chairman i believe strongly in the
background check process it's something
that works quite well here in
connecticut
it gives us an opportunity to make sure
that the person that's actually
purchasing the gun
has gone through a pretty strict
background check and all the databases
have been checked to make sure that they
are not a prohibited person
one of my greatest concerns for the men
and women that service the community
here in waterbury
is the amount of guns that they face on
the street on a daily basis
our police officers are taking an
average of one to two guns a day
illegal guns a day off the streets of
waterbury now we're a community of about
115
000 people here in connecticut so i can
only imagine
what my colleagues face in larger urban
areas across the country
um you know this is a this is a
significant issue for us and a great
concern for our officers
uh to be faced with these amount of
weapons that are on the street we've
seen a huge increase in spike in the
amount of concealed weapons permits that
have been applied for
over a 300 percent increase in weapons
of weapons permits applied for
here in the city over the course of 2020
and we've also seen a
tremendous uptick in the amount of guns
that have been sold the issue that we we
have is that
many guns are purchased here and they
are straw purchases
they end up in the hands of prohibited
persons and then they're used in crimes
of violence in our community
thanks chief senator grassley yeah thank
you mr chairman i'm going to ask my
questions in this order
chang solomon schwer and huff if i
get to all of you mr chang uh
thank you for your testimony about the
needs to vulnerable
communities to protect themselves can
you think of any instance where asian
americans
have needed to use firearms to protect
themselves
we don't have to look any farther back
than the 1992 la riots
and in korea town when
la was burning and korea town was under
attack
and they called the lapd for help
and the lapd was under resourced and
unavailable to come to the aid
of korean americans in koreatown so what
did they do
korean-americans utilized their second
amendment rights and took their own
personal firearms
and protected their businesses their
lives and their community
when police departments are defunded it
is often
communities of color that are most
impacted
so mr chang how does this impact the
need for self-defense with firearms
if we look back at the past year and a
half or so with coven 19
it's it's been a pressure cooker for all
of us to see
the civil unrest the violence that has
enraptured our country and when you
couple that with calls for defunding the
police and taking law enforcement
officers
off the street demoralizing them dehuman
humanizing them it makes
citizens like me feel less safe
and if i can't have law enforcement
there
to keep the peace in my community then
it is a rational conclusion
that individual citizens like myself
would opt to utilize my second amendment
right to purchase a firearm and use that
firearm
in lawful and legal self-defense okay
ms solomon you're a leader in the
national african-american gun
association so from your position
california is known to be a restrictive
state
in terms of gun control can you tell us
about california's approach to gun
control
which many are trying to reproduce on
the federal level and whether you think
that approach is effective
here in california there are a lot of
measures that we do see being paired
from the federal perspective
some that can work that works here the
private party
transfer process where all gun sales do
have to go through a dealer
that works well but there's other things
that essentially price
people in my community out of being able
to protect themselves
we don't have a blanket a concealed
carry weapons permit system here
those who live in affluent areas like
orange county or ventura county
can protect themselves better than
someone who lives in los angeles county
where black and brown people mostly live
so unfortunately the gun control
measures that
have happened here in california
essentially affects people of my
community
more so than people of other communities
where there are sharing relationships
with people in my community and law
enforcement
i'm going to have a second question for
you if i have time
otherwise i'll submit in writing because
i want to go to ms ware
we've heard a little about the universal
background checks
hr 8 and the extended background
investigation bill
h.r 1446 would these bills be effective
in reducing
gun violence uh
senator thank you for your question um
so when we're talking about gun violence
generally um as i mentioned in my oral
testimony
there's a real balance between how hr in
a
addresses a very small part of the
problem in publicly advertised private
sales
and how it would detrimentally impact a
larger part of the problem which is gun
suicides
normally when when people bring up
background checks uh and private gun
sales in particular they're referencing
impacts on mass public shootings and i
think it's important to recognize
that with perhaps only one um
one exception these would not have
played any meaningful role in preventing
any mass public shooting in recent
history
um perhaps um though i think it's
questionable the exception being the
odessa midland shooting
a couple years ago the the real problem
is that most of these mass shooters
actually
pass background checks to begin with um
that that there isn't this sort of
intermediate option for when they're
exhibiting
um very serious signs of of being
unstable and violent toward themselves
or others
um so that's actually more so than
background checks for prohibited persons
when we're talking about
mass public shootings the real issue is
that many of these people far too many
pass those background checks in the
first place
okay i've just got five seconds left so
let me ask dr huff
thank you for sharing your personal
story with us what measures do you
believe would be best
help others to avoid becoming victims of
gun violence
well quite honestly i think you know the
old boy scout motto always be prepared
i teach my sons when we walk into a
restaurant i used to have them close
their eyes
and would ask them where are the exits
you need to be able to act fast
i think people should be able to protect
themselves to the best of their ability
i think communities of color
and communities that are of minority
religious
entities should be very wary of
universal background checks
for the same reason that i mentioned
earlier it does
create a de facto gun registration
and then at any point in the future and
lord knows history has shown us
that bad things happen we
talked earlier about the the folks of
japanese descent during world war
ii um we've certainly seen it with the
jewish communities and
and with african-american communities so
i think
those folks in particular should be very
wary of universal background checks
anytime we have a term like common sense
gun laws
i think that's uh i think most of us
find it kind of humorous because it's
tagged common sense
so that you don't want to vote against
it right
but it's anything but common sense quite
frankly there are certainly things we
can do
again in my written testimony my my
husband talked about
my husband is a is a criminal
psychologist
and he talks about uh threat assessments
and how task forces can be formed
that would have prevented a number of
these things like in aurora
and in uh sutherland springs where
people knew
people knew that these people were
messed up before they ever got hold of a
gun
they could have been prevented
thanks senator grassley i'd like to
explain to the witnesses and others that
we have a role called beginning in just
a minute or two i'm going to leave to go
to the floor to vote
senator blumenthal is going to preside
and in the meantime i'm going to
recognize
senator leahy thank you mr chairman and
um i'm going to go back to
chief stagnolo if i might
i you know i should note that i'm a gun
owner
i go through background checks whether
i'm buying a pistol or a rifle in
vermont it's usually somebody who's
known me
selling something to be known me my
whole life
but i i have no problem with that
uh it was a background check and i
i worry about the straw purchases
i knew when i was a prosecutor and i've
seen it since so many
guns are bought in straw purchases and
end up in criminal hands there's no
federal law that adequately
addresses this type of firearms
trafficking
there's more we can do to stop these
purchases
yesterday i introduced a bill to do just
that with
uh senator collins of maine and
chairman durbin the last time we had
that bill up before the senate he got a
58 votes and bipartisan votes
is supported by a broad range of law
enforcement
organizations so chief spagnolo
do you agree that legislation explicitly
targeting straw purchases will help law
enforcement keep firearms out of the
hands of dangerous criminals
yes i do i think that would be one step
senator uh
in the process you know we work closely
with the united states
attorney's office here in the district
of connecticut uh you know
looking at straw purchases and having
local and state
investigations adopted by the u.s
attorney for federal prosecution under
the project safe neighborhood doctrine
and it works quite well you know the
thing is is in connecticut here we have
a background process and
and you know there's there's
plenty of guns that are sold and then as
i said you know forensically we're able
to link these guns into shootings that
are happening in our community
and it's really devastating when i when
i was chief law enforcement officer of
my county
i heard from so many uh the police will
say
they feel safer when fewer guns end up
in the hands of criminals
it's kind of an easy question i i assume
you felt the same way the police
officers
were under my jurisdiction felt
absolutely senator thank you and uh mr
chairman i'd like to introduce in the
record letters
supporting our legislation from
four law enforcement agencies the
national
fraternal order of police the major
cities chiefs association
national sheriff's association and the
national district attorney's association
without objection and uh
if i could ask robin thomas since 1996
congress explicitly prohibited federal
agencies from researching the gun
violence
epidemic the ban was driven by the bogus
conspiracy theory that
federal research into gun violence would
lead to federal assault and second
amendment rights when i was chairman of
the senate appropriations committee i
helped end the funding drought in 2019
we appropriated 25 million to the cdc
and nih
to study gun violence from a public
health perspective
any other epidemic killing tens of
thousands of americans each year as a
public health
uh epidemic ms thomas why is it so
important for the federal government to
treat and research gun violence
as a public health epidemic why is it
vital for congress
to fund that thank you for your question
senator and thank you for your
leadership on this issue
we are so appreciative of the new
funding 25 million dollars which is
going to look at this issue more
carefully
we know for from early studies
in the early 90s initially on this issue
that when we study and look at rates of
gun violence
and the types of measures that can be
put in place to reduce it that we get
really interesting and important
information about gun storage about gun
sales about limitations on
guns that are appropriate to reducing
violence that's why the dickie mm was
put in place to ensure that we don't
have research in order to be able to
speak knowledgeably about the ways we
can reduce it
so we really look forward to seeing the
outcome of this research which we know
because we do have
private research that's been coming out
of really high-end universities across
the country
showing the positive impact that gun
laws make
in reducing gun violence whether it's
limitations including background checks
or permit to purchase laws
safe storage laws and so many more so
this is essential because without this
research to show the impact
it makes it a difficult argument and we
know when research is done it shows
the impact of these laws and helps us to
have an educated
informed conversation as a country about
what actually works
and miss thomas i'm going to submit
another question to you for the
record if i can because i also want to
ask chief spagnolo
the congress prohibits the atf from
making gun records
this possession is digital digitally
searchable that means they're
going through millions of paper records
that are stored in cardboard boxes by
hand
it is absolutely ridiculous do you
believe that empowering the atf to
utilize 21st century
tools like digital searches would assist
law enforcement agencies
trying to trace used in crimes
yes gun tracing is an important part of
investigations that we uh
we participate in um with gun crime and
anything to
um progress that and bring it up to
today's technology would be beneficial
to law enforcement
thank you very much thank you mr
chairman thanks senator leahy
uh senator lee thank you mr chairman mr
chang i'd like to
start with you in your testimony you
talk a little bit about the racist roots
of
gun control and i wanted to know if you
could elaborate a little bit further on
this
and talk to us a little bit about the
disproportionate harms that you think
can be inflicted on minority groups
of various stripes including lgbtq
communities
uh by gun control uh aggressive gun
control policies
uh uh of the sort that are often pushed
these days
including things like universal
background checks and increased waiting
periods
thank you senator for the question so um
i think a lot of gun control laws under
consideration that are passed or always
well-intentioned right well-meaning and
i think we are all united in the fact
that we want to reduce the violence that
we see in our country
like i mentioned with executive order
9066
as one of many examples it was
under that that executive order was
ordered under the guise of public safety
and national security yet it took a
marginalized community our japanese
american citizens and unconstitutionally
put them in internment camps
i think the main point is we have
this tendency to create the other
right and when we otherize people we
stop
treating them like human beings and then
we stop
saying that they have the rights
bestowed upon them by the us
constitution
and so whether it's with japanese
americans
or any other asian americans or lgbtq
americans
it's it's us today but it's going to be
someone else tomorrow so this isn't just
a problem for the asian american
community or the lgbt community
but when there are gun control bills
under consideration
it is it's it's it threatens every
single american's rights to defend
themselves
from real imminent threats and that's
what frightens me
about the the gun control legislation in
front of this body today
very often not only in american history
but um
even prior to american history
we've seen that it's rarely the
empowered very very rarely the wealthy
or those
with political connections to the
government who have their rights
interfered with this goes back many
centuries
charles ii in england in something
called the game act enacted in 1671
uh it took away gun rights of commoners
17 years later in 1688
william and mary brought into the
english bill of rights
legislation that protected gun ownership
rights
for commoners but made clear that it
applied only to protestants
in other words those who aren't
disenfranchised those who are not
uh among the wealthy elite or the most
well-connected
are usually those uh in any society
certainly going back hundreds of years
in our legal traditions
those are very often not the people
whose
rights are most seriously restricted the
wealthy and the well-connected end up
doing okay
now dr hub i i appreciate you joining us
today
and it's good to hear your voice again
and and to um
hear your insights on this your story is
nothing short of
tragic and heartbreaking uh
now the the right of individual
americans to keep and bear arms
uh what was appropriately considered by
our founding fathers so
fundamental uh and so associated with
the the english legal tradition that
informed their decision making
uh that they chose to put it in to the
constitution in the second amendment
recently my home state of utah became
the 17th state to enact
constitutional concealed carry
legislation allowing anyone 21 years
of age or older who's legally allowed to
possess a firearm to uh concealed carry
subject
to um to certain exceptions dr hub
could you explain why you think it's in
the public interest
uh setting aside for a moment the
constitutional questions but why is it
in the public
interest to allow all law-abiding
americans
to carry firearms
oh heavens that that becomes so deep
um i think you and and mr chang
put it very clearly when you're looking
at the broader picture
i i know that historically
um bad things can happen
and i think it's a preventive uh
for a honestly for a future
or future despotic actions makes it very
difficult for someone to come in
and do bad things to groups of people
when they can fight back
as individuals i think we see so many
people who are
in persecuted classes um i think the lb
uh what is it now the lb
lbgq i forget all the letters now but
i think those persecuted classes are
particularly
in need of protection personal
protection
i think it's important that the bad guys
don't know
where the guns are i think that the more
that we see these
mass shootings we're seeing them in
places where people
again are not allowed to protect
themselves
i think when we see them in schools
that's a perfect example
it's always bothered me that that my my
sister's a teacher
she can protect herself at the walmart
you know across the street from the
school
where there are mothers pushing
strollers and yet for some reason
society has said
we don't trust you the minute you cross
the street and go into your classroom
and yet that's where the bad guys go to
kill people
so i think the more good people that are
armed the better
in other words a lot of this has to do
with the fact that if we didn't have
these rights government would have a
certain monopoly
on the use of force now if you live in a
neighborhood that's well secured
that's behind a a gate
if you can afford your own private
security or if you're in a neighborhood
that
uh for one reason or another the police
monitor regularly
this might have a very different set of
implications than it would if you
don't live in one of those communities
would you agree with that
i absolutely would agree with that and
i've noticed that uh many of the people
that are supportive of gun
control have their own security details
i unfortunately i i don't have that
charles ii and william and mary
certainly had their own
as well thank you
thanks senator lee uh senator feinstein
thanks very much mr chairman uh one
proposal
to address gun violence is by passing
extreme risk laws my state california
did just that
these laws allow family members and law
enforcement
to go to court to get temporary lawful
orders to prevent people
from purchasing or possessing firearms
if they are a danger
to themselves or others before each of
the tragedies
in tucson aurora navy yard
and santa barbara family members and law
enforcement
saw warning signs but they were
powerless to stop the shooter
from getting a firearm sadly this is
really all too common
a recent analysis of mass shootings in
the united states
between 2009 and 19
found that in 54 of those shootings
the shooter had shown warning signs
so here's the question and i'd like to
have each of you briefly address it
do you believe that extreme risk laws
would help reduce gun violence on a
national level
please um okay i'll start on the side
um absolutely yes extremist protective
orders
um fully comply with due process they
are an incredibly effective tool for
family members and law enforcement
both in preventing suicide which is the
thing that takes the most
american lives from gun violence and
also
from preventing mass shootings a recent
study in california
identified at least 21 instances in
which mass shootings had been prevented
by the use of extreme of extreme risk
protective orders and
the chief pointed to data coming out of
connecticut about the reduction in
suicide
directly attributable to extremist
protective orders so when these measures
are approached in a way that
utilizes full due process judicial
officers testimony under oath and a full
and fair hearing within a short amount
of time
there's absolutely no reason we
shouldn't have the supplying across the
entire country to help prevent
suicides mass shootings and other
violence thank you
anybody else on that question please go
ahead okay
um geneva solomon here i do agree
um with what she said you know with the
gifford style office however
we have to be careful with how we you
know implement those laws
oftentimes you know extreme worst and
red flag laws
affect people more within minority
communities
because there is still a stigma attached
to those who are within minority
communities practicing responsible gun
ownership as being
irresponsible so although the family
member may call
and bring in law enforcement that law
enforcement officer
may not stress or implement
equally when it's someone from a
minority group and then someone from
you know a more affluent area so
oftentimes
you know those within the black and
brown community are affected more by
those red black laws
and sometimes guns are taken away from
them when they can and they won't be
able to protect themselves
anybody else yes please senator i would
like to address that as well
this is i think one of those areas where
there is uh
at least room for significant bipartisan
support on this
precisely because when you look at the
the general idea of targeted
interventions of people who are showing
these risk factors
um we're we're dealing with things that
again are targeted and not broadly
impacting people who are are not
likely to be a danger to themselves or
others and when you look specifically at
mass public shootings as i
mentioned to senator grassley earlier
the biggest problem
is that most of these individuals
despite these warning signs
were able to pass background checks and
obtain their firearms absolutely we're
able to
were able to pass background checks they
were not prohibited persons
because they hadn't yet reached um what
i'd consider either a mental health
crisis or
yet committed a felony under federal law
so this idea of targeted interventions
directed at people who haven't
yet reached that crisis point i think is
a very important
aspect of addressing very important
parts of the problem
now again with that there needs to be
adequate due process i think one of the
biggest problems with so many of the red
flag laws on the books
is that they don't adequately address
due process concerns
that there are very low standards very
low bars
for essentially taking away people's
guns on on the basis of
perhaps you know aggrieved former
lovers or people who are just upset and
it can be a very expensive
time-consuming process for innocent
persons to go through
so that needs to be balanced with that
same targeted
intervention approach thank you and i
would add that this is susannah
um senator feinstein i am thrilled to
say this is an area that you and i can
actually agree upon and i could
certainly work with you on this
um i'm not familiar with the piece of
legislation that you're actually
talking about um i agree with the last
speaker that obviously we always are
concerned
that laws like that can be misused
again in my written testimony i talked
about the difference between threat
assessment
versus risk assessment and
task forces at a statewide level
could be uh put in place that could
implement some very good rules on this
and i think would prevent a number
of future events thank you senator
clinton's time this is robin
thank you for the question yes we think
they will
extreme risk protection order laws allow
family members
and law enforcement to have tools to
take action
with due process before warning signs
escalate
to tragedies and i would finally have
that extreme risk protection orders
will indeed decrease the amount of both
suicides
and homicides we disproportionately talk
about mass shootings but every day
a hundred people die from gun related
suicide or homicide and
oftentimes unfortunately that involves a
domestic violence situation where
exchanged
boyfriend or husband
will try to take the life of their
partner an intimate partner violence is
an
unfortunate reality every day in america
last time i was on call
a boyfriend at five o'clock in the
morning came to his girlfriend's house
and shot through the door trying to take
her life
and extreme risk protection orders will
help prevent those events
thank you senator i know we're running
out of time here but if i may just very
quickly add one more point um so i think
it's important
um to also recognize an aspect of um
these targeted interventions um that has
to deal with i think that the lack of
trust right now between the second
amendment and gun owning community
and a lot of politicians and gun control
advocates there's this feeling that um
people are simply just out to take our
guns through whatever means necessary
um and i think one of the ways of
addressing that especially in building
that trust back especially
within the concept of red flag laws is
to ensure that these laws
focus on not just taking away people's
guns when they aren't showing these
warning signs
but that they're hooked up with existing
mental health treatment
addiction family court system
infrastructure so that we're not just
taking away guns but then directing
people
toward help and toward treatment because
ultimately their the goal of these
should be getting people back to a point
where they aren't dangerous where they
can have their rights fully restored to
them
because in the long run that's going to
benefit society much more it's going to
benefit that individual
and that helps restore that broken trust
between the gun owning community
and and a lot of politicians and gun
control activities thank you
thank you thanks mr thank you i will be
introducing a bill
thank you senator feinstein uh i would
just note that
uh to the last point that was made that
the risk warrant
law in connecticut provides for that
kind of access to help
in the course of the due process that's
afforded
whoever is separated from a firearm
and senator lindsey graham and myself
have actually offered
a bipartisan version of this risk
warrant law
in past congresses i hope that
i will have a republican partner in this
effort again
during this session because risk warrant
laws have been shown as
chief spagnola testified very powerfully
to save lives
not only suicides but in mass shootings
and other kinds of problems
and i'm very hopeful that connecticut's
model law which was
passed the first in the nation before
sandy hook
could actually be an example for others
to follow
there are 19 states that have it now
including florida in the wake of
parkland
and i think it's one of the most
promising areas
of progress on a bipartisan basis
senator cruz
thank you mr chairman uh miss hub
thank you very much for for telling your
story
your story is is powerful you and i have
known each other a long time
uh your story is one that i believe
anyone
assessing the the horror of gun violence
needs to hear uh and and needs to
confront
and and miss hub what i would ask you is
is
many members of this committee believe
that the right policy decision
is to enact strict federal laws
to make it harder for law-abiding
citizens to own firearms
do you believe in your experience and
your judgment
that disarming law-abiding citizens
makes our communities any safer
i absolutely believe that disarming
the average citizen makes for a much
more unsafe society
now your wheelchair ground bound
grandmother cannot protect herself
from the thugs who want to take her
social security check
if she has a weapon now she's on equal
footing
mr chang gun sales in the united states
skyrocketed in 2020 including among
minority groups
according to the national shooting
sports foundation
firearms sales during the first half of
2020
increased year over year by 51.9 percent
for whites
58.2 percent for african americans
49.4 for hispanics
and 42.9 for asian americans
why do you think that is thank you
question uh thank you senator for the
question
uh the fear in the asian american
community
is palpable and it's real and
asian americans are waking up to the
fact that we are americans and we have
the right
to exercise our right to self-defense
and if we want to use a firearm
that should be our choice and it
shouldn't be up to the government
to decide to determine how and when we
decide to defend ourselves
so i want to send a very clear message
to asian americans
that we are americans too
and we should be exercising every single
one of our rights
as american citizens and i want everyone
to speak up and contribute to this
critical debate and discussion
that we're having today about keeping
our country
safe and happy and let everybody live
the american dream
that we all want and we aspire to attain
thank you mr chang i think that was a
powerful and important message
do you believe that the right to keep
and bear arms
is a civil right and and to what extent
do you think the the additional firearms
purchases last year
uh were motivated in part by the the
riots we saw across the country as city
after city in our
in our country burned as as stores were
looted as
police officers were murdered to what
extent do you think individual citizens
wanted to be able to protect
their own homes and their own businesses
and their own families
uh in the wake of the violence they were
seeing unfold across our country
yeah putting the pieces together a
constant stream of civil
unrest of buildings and homes being
burned
of people of all races being attacked
the stress of being quarantined during
covid talk about defunding the police
demoralizing law enforcement encouraging
them to retire early or
just quit altogether because why would a
law enforcement officer want to put
their life on the
put their life on the line for a public
that doesn't want them i can empathize
with that
and so put on top of that the 149
increase in anti-asian american violence
you betcha asian americans are putting
all these pieces together just like
all americans are saying this is a more
dangerous
society that we've experienced over the
past year
and that's what we're experiencing now
and unfortunately it's only getting
worse and i don't want that and nobody
else wants that
but there is a logical conclusion that
if you're going to defund the police
and if there's going to be increased
violence and if i need to be my own
first responder that i need to have
a firearm to defend myself and my family
okay thank you final question miss hup
a couple of weeks ago i introduced an
amendment along with bill
cassidy that would have provided that
the 1400
stimulus checks going out from the
government not go to criminals
not go to criminals who are currently
incarcerated not go to mass murderers
and rapists and child molesters
uh we've who are who are currently in
prison we voted on it in the senate
floor
every senate democrat voted no and it's
failed by a single vote which means if
even a single democrat had supported
that amendment
we would not be currently sending u.s
taxpayer checks
to violent criminals including mass
murderers including presumably the
shooter in atlanta
the shooter in boulder including the
shooter in the mother emanuel church in
in south carolina including potentially
the shooter in santa fe and other mass
shooters who are currently incarcerated
miss up what do you think of the federal
government sending 1400
checks to mass murderers who carried out
acts of gun violence
so let me get this straight
i don't get a stimulus check one of my
sons
doesn't get a stimulus check but the
murderer
does i'm i'm shocked i'm horrified
i don't i cannot understand
what possible reason anyone would
have to vote against that senator cruz i
don't get it
thank you
we are on a roll call several members
are in transit
and so we're going to give senator
tillis an opportunity now
and we'll catch up on the democratic
side as
senators appear thank you mr chairman
thanks to all the witnesses
uh who are with us today and uh senator
cruz
i want to thank you for i want to fully
associate myself with your opening
comments and
with cruz grassley being reintroduced it
is something that i would like to get on
if you are working to get co-sponsors so
would like to do that as part of its
introduction
um mr chairman since i've been here for
six years now six and a half years um
the the the events of boulder colorado
are not the first one that we've had
in those six years they're very sad
situation the thing that i worry about
is that this is a time when you think
that we would all come together on
something that's common sense that makes
progress
but it tends to be the time to where we
go into our corners and we make no
progress
and i think that uh grassley cruz
is a step in the right direction and i
hope that it is something that we can
try and work on we don't know much about
the shooter in boulder
my guess is it's going to follow many of
the same patterns
that we've seen with other mass
shootings there were probably signs
that if we only had better uh better
resources for law enforcement
we may have been able to identify if the
parents
our friends or associates of the shooter
had uh spoken up there could have been
interventions to prevent it
i for one do not think that
a discussion around increasing gun
control along is to
gun control alone is too simplistic for
us to think we're going to make any real
progress
on the on a matter that we hopefully in
this congress will make progress on
so i i guess the
the the the challenge that i have with
those who think we should just have
indiscriminate red flag laws without any
due process
to be initiated by persons outside of
law enforcement
they don't make sense to me do they make
sense to you mr chen
my concern about extreme risk protective
orders
is that right now it's a patchwork
of different approaches by states and
it's just inconsistent depending on what
state you live in
the other concern i have to touch upon
your point senator is that
who should be trusted to make a final
adjudication and determination whether
someone is truly a risk
is that a judge is that a law
enforcement officer
should that be a family member or a
friend but
who actually knows this person well
who has an alter who might have a
negative ulterior motive
right to say i'm a disgruntled lover
or i you know i'm i'm i'm i'm upset at
you for whatever reason and therefore
i'm going to
leverage an extreme risk protective
order to take away your second amendment
rights
so at a high level i agree that there
there's an opportunity here and
and and what would that look like
i think it is probably up to this body
to help resolve these differences and
the patchwork right that we're seeing
across different states and that is a
tall order but if we take best practices
that we're seeing from different states
that's i think where we should first
look
but it is a balance of the individual
right
versus the right of the government to
take away someone's rights
at the uh on on behalf of public safety
and that's always
the difficult challenge i swear
thank you senator i agree that there are
indeed especially as they're written in
a lot of states significant due process
concerns i think
one thing we can do is look at similar
types of frameworks that we already have
in place that protect due process
in a more civil not criminal context
and one of those is in fact the mental
health civil commitment procedures
um so in most states these require
robust forms of due process there's
right to an attorney there's a right to
cross-examination
um you know there's a right to testify
on their own behalf
they use standards of clear and
convincing evidence which are fairly
robust
um and i i think using that
framework rather than a a
lower less robust framework is at least
a
starting point because there is a a
long-standing
both judicial review of these procedures
against the constitution but it's also
something that we're familiar with that
we know how to
run at least in terms of the framework
of due process
ms solomon
thank you for including me one of the
things that i haven't heard mentioned
when we talk about red flag laws is the
amount of money
that would cost to defend yourself when
that happens
as a federal license dealer here in
california we have seen people who have
relinquished their firearms over to us
and we've heard their stories
about how costly it has been due to a
disgruntled relationship due to
um an encounter that they have with law
enforcement and they spend
countless amounts of money and you know
and
a lot of time in court just to get their
firearms back two three years later
so we have to address that yes there
should be due process but
when we start to put a cost to that then
we get more into what i have been
continually saying is we begin to price
people out of being able to protect
themselves
thank you thank you mr chair thank you
senator tillis
again we have no democratic members
currently
in the room and i'd like to turn to
senator cotton and recognize him
first i want to begin by saying that
we're all saddened by the terrible
shooting in boulder colorado yesterday
so many americans i'm praying for the
victims of this crime especially
for the family of officer eric talley
i gathered mr talley left his work as an
information technology professor at the
age of 40
after a friend died in a dui crash
because he wanted to serve the public
he leaves behind a wife and seven
children
so we offer the deepest condolences to
them and their entire family and
community
he adds his name to the list of too many
officers who have
given their life in the line of duty
especially over the last few years
it's a hearing on gun violence and it's
true that gun violence has increased
especially
over this past year in fact all types of
violence have gone up
murders are up more than 20 percent
in the last year alone a single year
increase not seen in modern history
and murders have reached totals
nationwide not
seen since the 1990s
now our friends on the left always want
to go straight
to gun control as the solution for
reducing
this problem violence
before we start looking at controlling
the rights of law-abiding citizens
and regulating their guns and even
setting the grounds to confiscate
their guns why don't we look at why
this violence has increased to begin
with
notably there has been
extended systematic attacks
on our police and law enforcement
professionals
for years calling them racist
and bigoted and prejudiced demanding
that they be defunded
and replaced with social workers
when you condemn the police when you
make it harder
to do their job you shouldn't be
surprised
that criminals take advantage
of the opportunities that follow and
that crime rises and that in particular
violent crime rises likewise some on the
left like to complain about mass
incarceration
as if there are too many people locked
up in our prisons
when more than half of all violent
crimes don't even result in an arrest
much less a prosecution or a conviction
let me tell you a story about hassan
elliot in philadelphia
he's a member of a 1700 gang that's
responsible
for many mass murders in june of 2017 he
was arrested on a firearms charge after
threatening a neighbor with a gun
despite the criminal record he only
received seven months in jail
he then violated his parole he failed
drug tests he was arrested with cocaine
yet he was not sent back to jail and a
few months later
he allegedly murdered someone with a gun
when he should have been in jail
later he also murdered a police officer
all of this was preventable
if prosecutors had simply followed the
law
and supported their local police and
locked up
mr elliott as they should lock up so
many other
violent felons across the country so
what
should we do to reduce gun violence
the solution is simple we should support
our police we should enforce our laws
and we should yes lock up criminals
what we should never do is create new
vague
laws to restrict the constitutional
rights of law-abiding gun owners
all of these new restrictions fail to
stop criminals from breaking the law but
they do result
in liability for arkansans and americans
who responsibly own guns to protect
themselves
from the same criminals that are getting
away without real jail time
to commit crimes against innocent
civilians
when they should be locked away mr chang
it is well known that minority
communities are disproportionately the
victims
of these violent crimes including gun
homicides
if bills like these two house passed gun
control measures were to pass
which group would suffer more criminals
who are trying to get guns
often through illegal means with which
to commit
crimes or law-abiding citizens
especially
minorities who would like to purchase
guns for self-defense
thank you senator for the question the
group that would surely
suffer the most at the hands of gun
control bills would be minorities who
need
to defend themselves and the ones that
want to purchase a firearm for
self-defense
and i'd like to share a story about
what's been happening in my hometown of
san francisco
we've had multiple attacks on not just
asian americans but
vile disgust attacks been happening have
been happening to the elderly
asian americans and they have been
kicked and pushed and hit from behind
and they've
some have succumbed to their injuries
and to your point we have a district
attorney
who is somehow trying to rationalize
a murder by saying things like
the criminal had a temper tantrum
i don't understand how our district
attorney
and the oakland police chief right
across the bay who says that we
shouldn't defend ourselves that we
should just
be good witnesses we can't be a good
witness when you're dead
and if the public does not have the
confidence
in the law enforcement machine that can
that has the power to arrest
convict and jail criminals for their
actions
then that causes even more distress and
more of a problem in society in our
society
thank you mr chang and thank you for
raising the problem
of your george soros funded prosecuting
attorney one of many across the country
who refuses to enforce the law
and lock away violent criminals it's a
problem about which i'll be speaking
more at length in the future
thank you senator cotton senator padilla
thank you mr chairman um because i want
to
raise a topic in a frame that
i don't believe has been raised thus far
in
this hearing you know for most states
the age
required to legally purchase a rifle
and the age required to cast a ballot
are both 18. however there's some
shocking disparities
in uh legal state requirements for
obtaining a weapon versus
casting a ballot in 25 states
voters must be registered and have
specific forms of
id in order to cast a ballot but those
same
states allow people to buy rifles
without permits
and require no background checks for
some sales
additionally in a majority of states new
voters are
able to obtain a rifle quicker
than they're able to cast their first
ballot
it seems to me that we have our
priorities entirely backwards when it
comes
to this when we make it easier to buy a
gun
than we do to cast a ballot uh two
questions uh for mr rogers uh
you know what does it say to you that we
make it so much easier
in so many states in this country to buy
a gun than we do
to let people vote eligible citizens
and second maybe more specific to your
experience
given your efforts to address the trauma
and racial disparities at the community
level could you discuss your approach to
gun violence as a systemic
trauma physical mental in other words
[Music]